are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset
[Music]
phenomenon i'll take it phenomenon is a
good word it's a compliment okay that
was a compliment towards uh adam's uh uh
podcast quick plug in the first five
seconds
let's get right into it today
we have uh i've been away we didn't do
any poc i didn't do any podcasts last
week you did you had a great time doing
podcast last week yes sir uh today's
episode number 163 with michael francis
we got a lot to talk about michael's new
book that just came out uh mafia
democracy
uh which i have a ton of notes on we'll
get into a new wine you're launching
which we'll talk about as well
and the uh issues topics that we'll get
into guys we know what's going on with
gas prices we know what's going on with
the january 6th that they've been going
back and forth these last few weeks the
committees i'll get you know his
feedback his input what happened with uh
trump and his daughter commenting back
and forth about bill barr i don't know
if you saw that with william barr she
was mad at her right he was mad at her
for what she said
uh
first first
transgender children cheerleader in the
nfl i don't know if you heard or not
carolina panthers have the first
official
transgender cheerleader i want to kind
of get your thoughts like maybe the
market is demanding for that they want
to see more of that
uh and then a few other things you know
a lot of people have been asking about
the economy this week with biden and
their campus like this is the best
economy's ever been is it the truth are
people really
that optimistic about it
venezuela and iran had a meeting
together they signed a 20-year agreement
if there's two countries you don't want
signing a 20-year agreement maduro and
iran it's official they had that meeting
and a few other things that we'll get
into as well but having said that
michael thank you so much for being back
it's good to see you here great to be
here patrick
three cancellations on three different
airlines in two days to get here
not a weather related problem what's
going on what was it one specific
airline or was a different one united
yeah jetblue and america so all three of
three had cancellations and it was not
wasn't weather related what they tell
you they don't tell you we don't know
they don't tell you so what is it a
shortage of of workers i mean they can't
get people to to fly the planes i mean
you know
three airlines in two days cancellations
by the way i don't know if you saw the
article that came out about howard
schultz pleading his employees to come
back did you see this guy
howard schultz is pleading his employees
to come back begging them to come back
said he would get down on his
knees to get people to come back
and uh it's still uh it's still a
bit of a craziness anyways so your book
let me go through a couple things with
the book i looked at so you you go
through it you got
regulations you talk about in there
taxes you talk about lobbyists you talk
about tesla dealership you talk about
how other dealers other car dealership
and lobbyists play the role to hurt
tesla and selling cars directly to the
consumer
propaganda with the amount of websites
the federal government manages
congressmen in prison there was a
statistic you had in the book that
there's more congressmen in jail than
former mafia bosses let me say that one
more time there's more congressman
in jail then mafia boss says and then a
few other stats that will get involved
as well by the way yeah right so so tell
me what prompted you want to write this
book mafia democracy you know patrick
honestly i got seven kids six
grandchildren and i'm just you know
prior to the last
i would say 12 years i never was really
too much interested in politics
especially when i was on the street you
know we had a couple of politicians we
were dealing with and we did our thing
but i really started to pay attention
you know um in the in the obama years
and i am telling you
when i watch the movement i watch the
system i see how mob like that they're
acting very machiavelli and very mob
like i'll give you the the one
um uh phrase from machiavelli he says he
was advising his prince you read the
book you know he's advising him how to
maintain control of his kingdom and he
tells the prince you can do anything you
need to do you can lie you can steal you
can cheat you can even kill to maintain
control that's the number one thing but
to the outside world you must always
appear to be honest upright and have
integrity
and that's our politicians today
that's it in a nutshell you know and i
say this too you got a friend you got a
spouse she lies to you one time he lies
to you one time okay you give him a pass
you work it out second time start to get
a little what's going on here third time
you're really annoyed fourth fifth sixth
time that's it it's over
these politicians make campaign promises
they get on on video the next day
they're lying to us and everybody's well
that's politics it's not politics it's
lying and it's lying to the detriment of
the people that elect them in office to
help them and to help this country and i
see it happening so much i see this
machiavellian attitude and ideology
coming out that i'm worried about my
kids and grandkids this is not the same
country that i grew up in it really
isn't and it's not the same you know at
one point in time democrats and
republicans you know there wasn't they
weren't too far apart you know they're
not too far apart now
it's like there's such a divide
and this country is going in such a
wrong direction that i don't know what
it's going to look like in you know five
six seven eight ten years from now are
you really that concerned are you really
that deeply concerned i know you and i
have talked about it offline yes but to
the public that's not part of our
conversation are you really that deeply
concerned i really am i i really am
patrick as a matter of fact you know i
started writing this book five years ago
i was writing it for harper collins my
last publisher i get through four or
five chapters
and i did research and i started to talk
about politicians in jail and
regulations and all of that and i went
to my wife or you know well cami and i
said you know what what do i need this
for
i should i have no problems with the
government now these people are so
vengeful i've seen it all my life i said
i don't need to do this i go to harper
collins i gave him back my advance i
said i need to do this now
and i put it on his side
but the last couple of years what i'm
seeing is just so
it's just so terrible i said i got to
write this book i'm 71 years old what am
i going to worry about now
and i had to write it and and that was
and you know what
the gratifying thing for me is that all
the reviews and the comments that we're
getting people are really getting it
they're saying michael we see it we knew
it but you nailed it we get it we
believe it and they're even adding to
what i'm having to say when you were
when you were coming up as a a mobster
and you know you're you're doing what
you're doing with the family you're a
part of uh you're buying politicians a
lot of times they'll say well you know
it's easier to buy democrats as
politicians so it's easier to buy
republicans but your experience you said
you had an easier time buying democrats
as politicians why was that easier than
buying republicans they were easier to
corrupt i mean it's it's plain and
simple now we didn't say we're going
after democrats they just happen to be
the ones that we were able to get to you
know we would have got to anybody didn't
matter and by the way the book is
bipartisan it's not democrats not
republicans right down the middle i name
them both but for some reason you know
it was just easier to to work with
democrats why do you think though
because phil leonetti said when phil and
i spoke and you know we had him in the
in the in the studio we were
interviewing him
he said the opposite he says look it's
not just the democrats it was also
easier behind republicans you know for
him it was
uh he had as much frustration with
republicans as he did with democrats you
know but from your end why was it that
they would come up more from the why
would more democrats come up wanting to
do deals with you well you know i
there's a couple of them that i know
that were italian to begin with you know
remember i grew up in new york that was
our area there we had 750
made guys guys that actually took the
oath comprised all five families a lot
of us had neighbors friends relatives
that were law enforcement politicians
whatever so a lot of them were of
italian descent and a couple that i'm
i'm not going to mention the names now
but they were italians so maybe it was
just the jurisdiction and of course the
democrats were majorly in control in new
york so maybe there were more of them
they were easier they were on the street
we had access to them better but it
wasn't like we selected a democrat it
just happened to be that they were
democrats
yeah it uh you know you you sit there
and you think about like when we were
doing mafia states of america
and you know you guys talked about how
gambling used to be illegal now you know
it's it's a full-blown business model
billions of dollars being made
we talked about how you know hard money
lending was illegal now you got these
you know cash places around the corner
everywhere hey come bring your check
thirty two percent thirty three percent
fifty percent they charge more interest
than we did yeah okay literally across
the street you walk by it every single
day
the amp scott it's incred the the and
the racketeering there is these merchant
lending accounts whatever they are i
mean they're shylocks that's how they
are
absolute shylocks i mean they charge
more interest than we do than we did
excuse me then we did i don't do that
anymore
i want to be clear on let's clear the
air on that we did
it well michael can i can i ask you a
question on uh regarding your book and
regarding the the sentiment that you
basically said
the
the left and the right are so far apart
politically right now on the left the
aocs the socialists that that you know
on the right you want to call the
marjorie taylor green but you say
america's you don't even recognize it
anymore my question is
the people though i don't feel like the
people have moved super far left or
super far right i still think the
majority of people in america have the
same values want the same things for
their family want to have success want
to have a good life i don't think the
people have moved a certain
far left or far right direction what
have you run into as far as just regular
people go well i think we're seeing that
right now exactly what we were saying
you know unfortunately it's the
progressives that we hear from all the
time
but now that the country is going
through this economic strain
everybody i mean democrats republicans
they're all united in the same needs
listen you know i am a firm believer
that you know when it comes to uh voting
people vote first with their pockets
right they want to make sure they got
food on the table the rent is paid and
they're comfortable that way that's
number one you know and secondly
obviously safety people want to be safe
and that's shared by all americans
democrat republican doesn't matter we
only hear from the progressives and for
some reason
maybe because they got the loudest voice
i don't know what it is but
we have a tendency in this country to
really play toward the mind minorities
i don't know why it happens i don't i
don't know why we don't just shut them
down when they get so
extreme but for some reason we don't i
don't get it well pat uses an amazing
analogy you talk about there's certain
people you don't want to wake up
right
i mean would you would you break that
down you said there's a lot of people
just kind of going through the motions
working hustling doing their thing leave
me alone i don't want to be bothered but
at some point when you start pushing
somebody too much pushing they say you
know what
f this i'm sick of this exactly and a
lot of americans have kind of woken up
and said
i can't deal with this crap i mean even
think about where you're at you know in
l.a rick caruso right you here's a mayor
that's kind of like hey you know here's
what we're going to be doing people are
kind of listening to this guy he's
messaging saying we kind of like this
guy running at a democrat as a democrat
he's got a lot of conservative you know
fiscal policies how do you feel about
what he's doing right now in la
you know i don't trust any of them
that's that's my problem look i wish
i'll give you another example the guy in
new york what was what's his name eric
adams yeah eric adams i said okay you
know he seems like you know he's a he's
a law and order type of guy he's going
to straighten things out former police
yeah former police captain i'm not
seeing that
he ran on that platform and now he's in
and you know the guy's more more he
wants to dress up fancy and go to all of
these you know galas that he's going to
but i don't see anything happening in
new york so i reserve decision until i
really see what's going on with them
but um
i don't know patrick i'm i'm just so
leery of all of them at this point in
time
you do have to take a risk with somebody
though right meaning like you do have to
kind of say well you know like even uh
uh kai can you pull up what elon musk
said about caruso where you know he had
some nice words to say about caruso uh
so caruso's running for mayor of l.a and
you know people are making a lot of
noise about who he is and what he's
doing just type guy kai what are you
doing just go on google and ladies and
gentlemen kai's back in the building
doing what he usually do yeah i mean
so there you go that was so easy so you
just did that so but but there's a lot
of guys that are sitting there saying
this guy may actually get some of his
policies to pass you know he may
actually
uh get some people that may favor him
and say hey we we do want to get right
there where is the past friday elon musk
endorses caruso can you see that right
there click on that yeah can you click
on that kind there you go okay so if we
go up and see what he says there's a
tweet right there make that a little bit
bigger
los angeles is fortunate to have someone
like rick caruso running for mayor he's
awesome says elon musk wow kai could you
go back to the beginning the initial
article with the headline
if you could scroll up yeah
ex-republican back.
so is this what it takes to to win in a
place like la you're a former republican
who has to now
transition to a democrat right and
actually maybe you know
policy-wise you're more of a republican
but
personality-wise you got to pretend
you're a democrat that's how you kind of
got to win in l.a or california i mean
it's so tough to win as a republican
right i don't care you know you could
you could be a republican with democrat
values and still call yourself a
republican and it would be tough
so maybe he's got the right formula i
don't know but i mean i like him so far
but
you know listen a great sign for me in
california was the fact that they threw
the attorney general out of
san francisco
threw him out you know in the recall and
hopefully the next one will be what's
his name from l.a because he's another
garcetti oh no not the garcia that's the
mayor attorney general's name
what's his name
forget his name latino i dislike no i
dislike these guys so much i can't even
i get mad at even thinking about why
why do you get mad thinking about these
guys
patrick
they've identified in the city of la 17
gangs
that are following people to their homes
that they're they're tracking them in
restaurants and this isn't the these are
gangs that could be indicted under the
rico statue because they're criminal
enterprises they're very sophisticated
they're tracking people from their
restaurant to their home
and and robbing them at gunpoint at
their home they've identified 17 gangs
the lapd now has a unit just for this
gang violence
you can go into stores rite aid stores
and and other pharmacies that are
closing left and right in all of
california because now shoplifting is a
misdemeanor for anything under a
thousand dollars people are going in
there writing broad daylight on camera
don't care and taking 950 worth of
merchandise off the shelf and walking
out of the store and nothing happens to
them
i mean people are not going to tolerate
this normal working people blue they're
not going to tolerate this doesn't
matter democrat republican or whatever
but this is what's this is what is going
on now i'll ask you a question what is
the reasoning behind this
now of course we're hearing that soros
is putting all of these people in he's
backing their campaigns he's getting
them in office but even there what's
what's the reasoning behind it i i don't
understand it why do you want criminals
to be pampered so they can go out and
commit more crimes and you want you know
regular citizens to be the victims and
do nothing about it what's the mentality
behind this
you know i consider myself fairly astute
i can't figure this out i don't know
what the plan is
is it somebody that's really looking to
destroy america from within
you know is that what's really happening
in these major cities
i i don't i don't know but why would you
do that though because
even the guy sometimes even the guy
that's going through it that he's
relying on everybody else but you know
hey i'll give you this for free i'll
give you that for free
even if they bring the whole empire down
they get crushed because they're not the
creators and the initiators
they rely on the creator and the
initiator you know but maybe they're
oblivious to it maybe it's an ego thing
maybe it's
you know
if you rarely earn anything in life you
really don't care whether anything you
lose anything you never build it in the
first place to have any kind of
uh uh
responsibility or pain of loss
uh who knows what the motive is with
that but you know sometimes you gotta
sometimes certain states you know
jedediah on her podcast
that got started last week on the first
episode she just flat out said listen if
you're living in these cities and states
leave i have potatoes just leave i lived
in new york she's saying this i was in
new york i left if you're living in
california leave if you're living in
chicago illinois leave why are you
staying there they have to feel the pain
that you're leaving too many people are
sitting there saying oh
no i'm just going to stay here because
of this and because of that no listen
i'm leaving here's what i'm doing i'm
going to a different state that's her
position where maybe eventually it needs
to get to a point where they're gonna
sit around and say
uh guys we're losing way too many people
just yesterday you know they're having
this conversation with um msnbc is
having a conversation with uh one of
their uh guests that's sitting there
saying well it's not that bad gas prices
are not this it's the putin putin uh gas
hike did you see that which which story
is that by the way the that's in the
middle of page two with uh you're
talking about uh
nbc host willie geist yeah willie geist
yeah nbc willie geist he says i want to
read this to you he says uh
uh nbc host tells biden official that
americans see right through the his
putin price hike spin okay this is msnbc
saying this you can't lose msnbc maybe
you lose a little bit of jake tapper
from cnn fine but you cannot lose msnbc
willie geist told the director of white
house national economic council
friday that americans are not blaming
russia president vladimir putin for
soaring gas prices brian it's true of
course that russia's war in ukraine has
impacted oil prices yes but i promise
you the landscaper two days ago i talked
to about gas pump who was trying to fill
up two cans uh and backpack blowers and
mowers in his truck was not going damn
you putin so what do you say to him what
do you say to families who can't afford
all these groceries
right now the nac director brian rose
brian dee said these gas prices uh which
exceed five dollars per gallon uh
thursday is hitting families hard then
he said gas prices have increased a
dollar seventy since putin amassed
troops at the ukraine border i think
eventually these arguments get exposed
even yesterday or not yesterday three
days ago when
bill maher had kellyanne conway on
and who's the other person that he on he
had he had a few different people on and
he said look guys
if kavanaugh is getting a death threat
and new york times doesn't cover it the
next day if that was a democratic
supreme court it would be right it would
be a cover story he says this is the
hypocrisy of new york times where people
don't trust and it's not coming from
tucker carlson that's coming from bill
maher
you can't lose these people that you've
had for decades and that's what's
starting to happen to many of them i got
to tell you this i was never a fan of
bill maher's mainly because i didn't
like the way he treated christians and
you know and he was religiously
religious
you know yeah religious yeah but um and
also because i thought he was really far
left
but as you're watching him now i have a
different opinion of him i mean i like
him more now because he's calling it as
he sees it and listen
i mean he said it right out with the new
york times but you know it's it's a
deeper issue
this was a supreme court judge that
somebody went up to his house and was
saying they were going to assassinate
him and here we are with mainstream
media and not even wanting to cover it
i mean
what are they thinking
i mean this is
patrick this is worse than street stuff
i'm telling you i mean these people say
it's okay to kill a supreme court judge
they don't want to cover it they want
they want people to know that
i mean how do you start that what kind
of mentality is going on in this country
and that's why i'm saying this has
become more mob like even the press even
the media to cover things up like this i
mean this is serious stuff yeah they
would talk about how schumer
uh
remember when schumer said hey
absolutely he'll pay the price for row
resurfaces and he said it passionately
and some are saying wait a minute that's
a threat you know and he says you know
uh uh i want to tell you you know i want
to tell you kavanaugh you have released
the whirlwind and you will pay the price
you won't know what hits you if you go
forward with these awful decisions right
and then he has to come back this is
schumer's word now some people may say
well that sounds like what happened at
the january 6 when trump said this
entire
so the point becomes this then the view
i don't know if you saw the view or not
you don't seem like the type of person
that watches the view religiously
although it's a it's a very good show to
watch if you like to increase your blood
pressure it's a very good show to watch
but you see them saying well well yeah
and then but
yeah but you see what he's saying you
see what mcconnell said you see what
they said no here's what's going on
hypocrisy at its best
all across the board and it's being
revealed fyi it's both the left and
right and if you try to impose hypocrisy
it's eventually gonna be
losing like guns right now the debate
that they're having with guns right now
where
you know 10 senators from the outside
they're sitting there saying hey so
here's what we propose because i don't
know if you saw matthew mcconaughey's
speech today did you actually watch
so i watched the speech and i'm sitting
there this is a guy i'm a second
amendment guy
i have multiple m16s i have shotguns i
have guns i'm all for it i think i want
everybody to be trained but you're
sitting there listening to this guy
saying okay
uh yeah i wouldn't mind more people
being trained i can see why the age may
increase from 18 to 21 i can see that
okay fine background check fine when i
was in dallas
i went to the local gun shop i bought an
m16 with a magazine and full of rounds
and it took me i bought it i went walked
into the store at 11 41
by 11 59 i left with everything
bought it walked out nothing
i'm a safe guy to buy that stuff and
then i made a video about it to document
it but
should the average guy be able to do
that should the average guy be able to
do that if he's taking medication some
people are making these proposals why
don't we look at them right but the same
thing goes also with nra you know they
also don't want anybody to make any
changes to talk about anything
i think what's happening today is the
following
row v wade hey here's what's going to
take place i can't believe you're doing
this
guns this is what's i can't believe
you're doing this but the american
people are saying
look
this sounds reasonable this sounds
reasonable the unreasonable folks you're
so loud you're convincing the reasonable
people that you have a point and you
don't okay what are your thoughts about
what's going on right now with what
they're proposing with the new
gun laws
well here's my thinking first of all i
don't think anyone at 18 years old
should be able to walk into a gun shop
and come out with a gun not at 18. i i
disagree with that you know they talk
about the military it's such a silly
comparison when you go into the military
they're training you how to use the gun
discipline authority they they're giving
you training on it not letting you go
out in the street and do that so i think
18 is the wrong age i wouldn't i
wouldn't have no problem with seeing it
at 21 i have no problem with background
checks at all i don't you know for me
look patrick here's here's what i said
if they made drunk if they make
guns illegal the only people that are
going to have guns are those on the
street the criminals i could have gotten
any gun i wanted within 24 hours all i
had to do was put it out there anything
that i wanted i would have had when i
was on the street anything there's more
illicit guns on the street than you
could imagine maybe 200 million
that's the numbers that are elicited
well illegal
yeah
200 million you can get them in a second
believe me so why would you take guns
out of legitimate people's hands
that are using them for the right reason
and maybe to defend themselves it makes
no sense so many things that these
people talk about make no sense but i am
all for
logical reform i don't think a kid at 18
should have a an m16 what are you going
to do with it
why
you know no proper training at 18 most
guys are so immature anyhow at that
point in time so i like logical changes
you know to things that make sense and i
think most of american people think that
way too you know it's the same way look
you know roe versus wade is such a
hotbed people don't even understand
what's happening they're not saying it's
illegal they're saying it's it goes to
the state which it should have been in
the first place i agree with that it's
up to the states to decide if you have a
blue state and in that blue state people
think abortion is okay and they voted in
i'm against it i'm a pro-life guy but
hey you know what it should be in my
opinion the state should decide that if
you're in a red state and they say no
then
then there's no abortion uh you know
but look i was incensed i did a video on
it on my channel and uh when uh the
mayor of new york
gets out there i can understand the
reasoning behind this and he said that
abortion should be legal right up to the
time of birth
and it's a health issue for the mother
now he didn't follow it up and say the
mother's health was at stake you know
her life was at stake and i don't care
what anybody says i mean my daughter i
have five daughters my youngest one was
born you know premature and now she's
the biggest out of all my kids and all
my daughters but i'm saying that's a
human life attached only by an umbilical
cord how can you say the health of the
mother is at risk it's murder plain and
simple but why would a guy make a
statement like this who is he pandering
to i don't think the normal american per
believes that so who is he pandering to
a minority of people that that agree
with something like that no he's just
he's just pandering to the people that
are probably
funding or some people that he needs
their endorsement or some people that if
they piss him off
you know they may not get the support
wanting to be invited to those parties
because deep down inside he himself
knows that that doesn't make i have to
believe that a logical reasonable person
has to believe that doesn't make any
sense to make a comment like that okay
it makes no sense yeah it's the same
thing i'll give you another example they
want to go soft on crime with criminals
right i spent eight years in prison and
20 years on the street do you think if
giuliani would have came to me and said
michael we're going to soften the
racketeering laws and we're going to
give you a bell if you get in trouble
don't worry about it do you think i
would have said oh you're such a nice
guy i'm going to go straight
i'm not going to commit crimes anymore i
would have said this guy losing his mind
it's open field
if you're lessening the the uh
consequences for a criminal they're
going to take advantage of it yeah so
what
i'm asking you patrick and you adam
you're intelligent guys because i can't
figure out what the reasoning is behind
this they're losing they have to be
losing most of the people that don't
agree with this
people want to protect themselves they
want to be safe in their neighborhoods
what is the reasoning behind people
acting like this and going soft on
criminals and really making you know the
innocent people the victims that but
they think they think that's what the
voters want but how and they don't but
they they but they don't that that's the
beautiful thing about okay so
you know a guy asked me a question the
other day
and he's making two 300 grand a year
and he says
hey can i ask you a question
how do you relate to people that only
make 15 bucks an hour i said what do you
mean he said how do you relate i'm
making you know 250 000
how do you relate to people that make 15
bucks an hour i said bro you were just
making 15 bucks an hour three years ago
what are you what are you talking about
yeah but you know when you're saying no
no relax
you've officially been disconnected from
the customers that are buying from you
you don't even know what's coming next
for you when you start thinking that
you're that much bigger than somebody
that's making
15 bucks an hour because you're making a
quarter million dollar your income right
it was an interesting company he was
asking you or more asking for himself
yeah he's like well you know when you're
winning again you know it's like you're
making a quarter million how do you
relate to people the mindset of a
fifteen dollar an hour person like you
were there a few years ago but you don't
bro so but this is the point though
when you're disconnected from the life
and the only people you talk to
are people that are within your circle
and they're
going to the same parties the rich
congressman senators and you're in it
for too long
you forget that you got into this with a
cause to want to make impact to want to
make a difference to correct an
injustice now you're just attending a
party on a daily basis you're so
disconnected from the day-to-day stuff
you don't even know what's going on in
the streets so they don't go in the
streets and say so tell me how does it
feel like paying gas prices the amount
that you're paying how you how are you
feeling right there well it's tough why
my grandmother lives two hours away from
here i can't even go visit i used to go
visit her once a month i can't do that
anymore i told my grandma i can't come
by why two hours away i drive a pickup
truck it's 70 miles per gallon i just
can't pay the six bucks so i'm not gonna
be doing it that's real that's the real
part a flight that used to cost 350 i
used to take this flight all the time
it's 350. now the flight is
580. i can't pay 580 right the flight is
gas you can't pay that the food like by
the way some basic prices that people
feel okay so
fuel prices in the last 12 months year
over year up 107 percent airfare up 38
hotels and motels up 22 percent
butter and margarine uh 20
okay then you have ground beef made to
make up 14 bacon up 15 eggs up 32 apple
up six percent fish and seafood up 12
percent you see these stats that's
coming from department of labor and who
feels this you know who feels this you
think nancy pelosi feels this the
average person
average person who's shopping is going
to build this stuff what about the woman
the congresswoman from i think michigan
the other day she said i don't care
about the gas prices they don't bother
me i drive an electric car
now she rep she has constituents and
she's
lame enough to say something like this
publicly he's a newspaper
i have an electric car of course they're
57 000 how many people can afford that
because they're already paying off the
car that they have
so yeah we just go out and buy an
electric car i don't care about the
price of gas she had the nerve to say
that it shows you how far detached they
are
and these are the people that are making
decisions for us that's what i'm saying
patrick this is it's gotten so far out
of hand and if this continues on this
path
we're in a lot of trouble i don't think
we are i don't think we are and here's
why
i think it's very important for
everybody to read this
to be aware of what's going on i think
everybody needs to read this to
understand what's going on they got to
pick up the book but spend the whatever
30 how much does this book 20 bucks 15
bucks yeah whatever the dollar amount is
go buy the book put the link there so
people can find it by the way let me let
me just mention yes if they go on uh
mafiademocracy.com
we'll give them a free chapter to read
then they can make a decision okay there
you go put mafia democracy.com but but i
don't think
you know
bad times are
gonna be around the corner permanently i
think temporary they're gonna be here
and it's gonna be ugly especially those
who are oblivious and they've spent too
much time watching netflix playing video
games spending too much time on tick
tock instagram yeah those guys i'm sorry
you paying the price because the news is
gonna hit you 12 months later than the
people that are aware so you're going to
get hit very very hard but the people
that are actually the common sense
people here's what they're noticing
they're noticing
hypocrisy and contradictions for example
let me kind of go through this what's
wrong with us
raising the age of somebody using an m16
to 25 years old
what's wrong with raising the age of
somebody using a gun at 21 years old
this is an 18 year old kid do you
realize when you're even in a military
even a soldier
us we can't keep the gun in our bed we
have to go put it in a place where they
keep it safe
sign it out it's not with me all the
time which they're right that's how i
was in the army okay
yeah you have a good point i'm sorry
oh but it's okay if a
eight-year-old kid wants to change their
sex
it's okay for us to give
the hormone medication where now they're
gonna make why i don't know if i'm a man
or oh you know what okay babe so so you
think
the 18 year old is not wise enough to
use a gum but you do think the 10 year
old is wise enough to
have a sex change okay so now you lose
because it's called hypocrisy
now you're contradicting yourself you
lose when you say it's my body my choice
and you go to lakewood church screaming
hollering getting naked half naked
taking your clothes off down to your
panties and your bra sports bra it's my
body my choice i can do whatever i want
to do with it okay cool that's all right
it's cool
uh listen man you know this vaccine
stuff
i mean my family's taking it i don't
want to take it let's just say no you
have to you're being irresponsible
that's contradiction okay so yeah let me
tell you it's the woman's choice when it
comes down to this okay but i have to
pay for it why do i have to i didn't
have the fun enjoyment that you had when
you had sex you enjoyed it i didn't
shiver you shook my toes didn't curl
your toes curled why am i having to pay
for yo your toes curling i didn't get
that experience you got it okay well so
so what is taking place today
is
contradiction on both sides are being
revealed and people are starting to say
i read between the bs
a bill maher is reading between the bs
fox news the other day
they're sitting there preaching all this
stuff about transgender they just did a
special on transgender i don't know if
you saw that or not the story that they
had on yeah i watched did you see it or
no i watched did you watch the special
that they had where i've been watching a
lot of stuff from matt walsh these days
have you seen what he's putting out
there with i am a woman or have you've
seen it a woman what is a woman yeah
fascinating yeah but but what i'm saying
is now fox fox is putting it up it's
kind of like well so now fox is sitting
there saying well you know we got to go
a little let's see what the audience
wants to hear so
your fox news
contradicting yourself and people are
sitting there saying what are you
pandering to so it doesn't matter which
way you go the average person is sitting
there saying i've never liked bill maher
but that just makes sense i've never
liked tucker carlson but that just makes
sense i've i just found out about joe
rogan i know hundreds of millions of
people listen to billions of views
online i found that because of what they
said and guess what i actually like what
the guy has to say risk russell brand
guy isn't he supposed to be a full-on
left-wing you know a liberal guy this
guy makes sense
people are starting to say
hey
i don't know i think there's a lot of
contradiction and they're they're going
to people who are able to reason and the
value the currency like you know how
hard work is a very valuable currency
right
respect is a very valuable currency okay
being able to reflect is a very valuable
currency right good attitude good
attitude very absolutely very valuable
currency loyalty very valuable currency
you know what people are starting to
realize is a very valuable currency the
ability to reason common sense wow you
want to hear something that's very
telling i was at the airport going
through security and we're going through
the machine right there's five women in
front of me and for some reason the uh
tsa guy says i need a male to come
through
so i said i qualify that is that okay
right crowded place everybody started
laughing
you know because they get it
now if there was maybe progressives
there i would have offended somebody and
i even said to him are you allowed to
say that he's come on through you know
like that but normal people are getting
it so i agree with what you're saying so
you know maybe this extreme
extremism that we're seeing that's
really caused a lot by the
you know i hate to say it because and i
want to ask you this question about
trump
this extremism
it's coming from the left i mean it's
coming from the far left i mean they're
the ones that put it out there the other
ones that shout the loudest they're the
ones that do all of that and they cause
so much division in the country i i
really think it's coming from there and
i and i'm i'm not picking on them i'm
just seeing it that's reality
but this extremism it's not what normal
people think they just don't think that
way i gotta ask you a question about
trump i can get on
and and talk i i try not to talk about
trump at all people know you supported
trump and i try to say them listen
this is not a personality con concert
contest for me i liked his policies for
america that's it yeah he's not going to
date my daughter i don't go out to
dinner with him we're not best friends i
don't go to mar-a-lago
this is one of i liked his policies and
the story but i forget about him i don't
talk about him i say something with this
current administration immediately they
don't even see that they come back at
trump
what is it
what did this guy do to make people hate
him so much
it's very obvious
it's very obvious i mean
you and i sat there and we spoke one
time and you told me about something you
learned from your dad years ago sunny
who had we had a chance to i had a
chance to meet with the most until we
had great lunch with them at that one
italian restaurant
and you said one of the things i learned
from my dad
is
to be able to sit down in front of
somebody
knowing they lied to your face knowing
they betrayed you
and you still
don't act like you know
and you don't publicly humiliate them
something like that and you know i'm
prefacing what you said but something
like that you remember this guy yeah
that was it yeah
so
well
trump didn't do that
trump went publicly and called everybody
out as fake news that means he called
everybody in a blanket
media you're a liars
and he kept doing it over and over and
over and over and over again you're
essentially questioning their character
you didn't say i disagree with their
policies he didn't say i disagree with
the approach to get the economy to
improve i disagree with what we ought to
do with health insurance no no you said
you're all full of [ __ ] you're all liars
you're all fake none of you guys care
about the american people all you care
about is your pocket your dinner and
that's who you are that's your dna well
guess what you did you woke him up
and that woke mop is coming after you
not one of them not two of them not
three of them all of them they're all
angry at you and no one's ever done that
before until this guy did it it's that
simple you go look at uh kennedy that
kennedy and his family did that behind
closed doors
but publicly like joseph kennedy was
like a trump john f kennedy wasn't like
a trump the father is a trump you know
he was a guy that if he would have ran
joseph kennedy was probably not capable
of running at that time because he would
have talked [ __ ] to everybody that guy
was a straight up gangster 100 you know
he was a he was a feared man but his
sons learned from dad's weaknesses and
strengths right like to like even if you
look at his daughter trump's daughter
look how he she got all the strengths
from trump's trump is like okay this is
what my dad's good at but look at the
way she answers okay you're like oh okay
i can see her there's diplomacy she has
diplomacy and the father doesn't have it
but
you know if if if we had a guy like that
right now would they put and be doing
what he's doing to ukraine how would
that phone call be handled they asked
the question from biden this week what
can we do about inflation you know what
his answer was there's really not much
we can do about inflation dude that's
not something we want to hear from the
president there's really not much we can
do about inflation there's really not
much we can do about inflation so i
think that's the part with trump where
he went out on the offensive and called
everyone's character out well let me add
to that because i i'm so glad you went
there michael because the whole time i'm
thinking as we're talking about all
these
policies issues substantive type stuff
all i'm thinking is the elephant in the
room is no longer there so
trump sucked so much of the oxygen out
of the room that even if you have if you
were going to attempt to have a policy
debate no matter what it was
you know health care guns schools
you know the economy whatever
everyone from the center to the left
would be like yeah but he's a liar yeah
he's a bad guy yeah he's not
presidential and it was such a quick
response that you couldn't even have a
substitute debate what's happening now
that trump is no longer in office and
the dust has settled
and we're supposed to have grown-ups in
the white house now and you have biden
coming out there basically saying yeah
you know the gas
you know it is what it is sorry you have
someone like janet yellen basically
saying
yeah my bad i was supposed to use i
heard i never used the word transitory
in my life never heard of it and i heard
it every other sentence out of
yellen and jerome powell transitory
transitory so
the good and the bad of the trump thing
is now that he's not here we can
actually have policy debates and that's
what's happening in this country right
now and
you know believe it or not
the right
is winning these policy debates for the
most part right maybe they've you know
on guns they may be you know
hopefully he'll come around on some
stuff
but
everything with wokism transgender
economy gas prices inflation it's so
hard to look at the left or bite in and
be like great job guys keep it up
the whole premise of biden and everyone
that kind of accompanied him into the
white house into the oval office was
quote unquote well now we got the
grown-ups in the white house is this
what [ __ ] growing up looks like
because it looks pretty ugly but without
trump we're able to see
really what's happening right now and
again not a huge fan of trump but at
least we're able to see
what's behind the curtain but but is
that is that okay so you just made a
very good point
uh and i rarely say that we just made a
very good point
and but but but the part about what the
part about what you just said is the
follow like he almost needed to leave
for us to know if he was doing a good
job or a bad job bingo yes god and now
we notice where he was doing a very good
job in and where he wasn't
and
a lot of the stuff that the media was
saying that he was doing bad they were
full of [ __ ] because yeah because they
it wasn't
the media would never attack the
policies for the most part there were
some things that were disagreeable you
know whether the tax cuts were a good
thing or not or whether you what you
want i mean he did not have a solution
whatsoever for health care right but for
the most part
when you talked about the economy blacks
whites hispanics latinos asians this
that like james carville said 1992 bill
clinton 30 years to the day like michael
said it's the economy stupid and
everything all roads lead to the economy
and
everything about trump it was he
everything was attacking his character
because like it or not the guy did lie a
lot
okay or he told fibs or whether he
called people out he i know but adam lie
a lot
i got what they all do is what you're
saying biden
can i tell you something people say we
feel sorry for biden and i'm a christian
and i'm a former gangster honestly
this guy i can't even look at him and
i'll tell you why number one he's a
tremendous liar
he's been feeding he's been living off
of the taxpayer for 47 years this guy i
guarantee never had to make a payroll in
his life he don't know what it is he's
been living off that
lie through his teeth about his son
lies he's his partner
he knows his son used him to get
whatever and he's sharing it the
evidence is there
and i'll tell you what gets me the most
and this is something personal i get
angry just talking about it what's
happening in our southern border
i spoke to 850 undercover dea agents
from the state of texas i spoke i spent
two days with them
they said what they said to me in two
days made me sick they said michael
we're not even getting 10
of the illegal drugs that are coming
across opioids and fentanyl
and then they they showed me something
they they wrote on a piece of paper a
block like this patrick maybe a foot and
a half
square and maybe two inches thick
and they said this block of fentanyl
coming across the border can kill the
entire population of the world seven
billion people and they said we can't do
anything about it
last year alone you know the numbers a
hundred thousand people between the ages
of 24 and 45 died of opioid overdose
including somebody very close to me okay
good beautiful kid some call he knows
this is happening
they know it's it's happening this 15
year old kids they're finding they're
finding opioids in their rooms in in
their in their lockers in school you
know this is happening and you allow
this because you bring it the whole
scheme is so easy to see you're bringing
these people in you want to get mail-in
votes then you want to send your troops
out at the election time and say hey
biden got you here if you want to stay
here you better vote this way you don't
need an id just mail the ballot in and
that's it it's all about staying in
office it's all about money and power
and control and that's what the book is
about let somebody deny that to me
let them deny it these are these are
they're murderers
i hate to say but it's true how could
you allow this look
i i don't know guys on the street that
would do this patrick i mean it we
didn't do this in our own neighborhoods
we took care of our communities even
sammy you spoke to sam we didn't mess
with our neighbor we took care of the
people in our neighborhood in our
community we had a heart for things like
that some guys okay talk about roy
demaio is different animal you know a
different animal but for the most part
how could you allow this to happen
is this that important to you nancy
pelosi
woman's 81 years old you've been in
power you're a multi-millionaire you
you might have come into how come these
people come into offices with
blue-collar assets and go out
multi-millionaires
on a 200 000 a year's salary
i mean this is what they're doing to the
american people and yes it's on both
sides but i got it for biden because i
know this is happening and he's doing
nothing about it nor any of the
democrats that right now are in control
and this this is basically murder
they're allowing it to happen you know
so many people that i've spoken to
because you know i travel the country
so many people that i've spoken to have
lost loved ones over opioid oh uh you
know what do you call it
overdose yeah i get so angry about it
yeah no i get it it drives me crazy how
could you allow this to happen biden i
don't feel sorry for him at all
i don't let me tell you something if i
was running for office and my wife knew
that i was abiding she would she would
divorce me for sure before she'd allow
me to be president
i mean you these people are all frauds
they're all frauds what are they trying
to do
biden's been office 47 years he's a
multi-millionaire you have to put the
country in this kind of shape go and
take care of your grandchildren live the
rest of your life enjoy yourself i don't
get it the nancy pelosi the same thing
go enjoy your life why do you have to
make people miserable
and this is coming from a former
gangster
but look i got kids and grandchildren i
got a heart i go speak in detention
centers talk to young kids
they don't real they they have to
realize what they're doing and they
don't care
and this to me is more serious than
anything else adam it i i take it
personal even if it wasn't a personal
thing and i would still take it personal
because they're wreaking havoc on this
country
and
if it is true and again i i can't verify
this i can't say it's a fact i know what
i've been told but if china
is sending the drugs to mexico mexico is
processing them and bringing them over
in their mules
well this is another thing that china
look you know this every great nation
that ever fell it fell from within roman
empire on down fell from within
this country now i think every young man
should go into the military
so many of them are soft they don't know
they don't even get i i mean they're on
their phones they don't even know what
it is you know to to to to break their
backs at all they should go into the
military you know that you've been there
and get training this country is getting
very weak our military is getting woke
you know
i ran in venezuela now partnership china
and i and russia getting to i mean
what's going on here i mean are we going
to be around in 20 years i know you say
different patrick but i don't know this
country is is getting weak from within
they call it the wussification of
america yes the highlights well let me
do i'm doing a sermon on on uh you know
at a big church greg laurie's church you
know who he is and you know what it is
it's what it what to be what is it to be
a man's man in 2022.
guys got to man up
i'm so i'm i'm really concerned i really
am about what's going on in this country
i think we're in a lot of trouble
i think it's going to unify the right
group of people
uh you know everything's in messaging
sometimes people don't have messaging
right and uh
people are getting the messaging in a
more uh way that's connecting with the
audience uh younger people are starting
some of the younger people are starting
to rise up and talk about some things
that we didn't talk about before
you got the
guys are talking about what it is to be
a man today and hey
you know something happens you rely on a
man to go fix this or do that and people
are starting to talk about this today
the last 30 years men have been
wussified you know whatever you want to
call it where
they're pansies but we're going back to
admiring what men's men are
and women see that yeah
where oh social you're even with the
what uh rollo is doing with some of
these guys people people are gonna get a
bigger voice on this jordan peterson
what he's doing is talking about
you know men you know
on the inside there's a monster it's
okay to be that because that's how we
are and we're supposed to be that way
and he's getting billions of eyeballs on
top of billy's eyeballs and people are
sitting there saying this kind of does
make sense and a lady interviews jordan
and says so look at me i'm 45 years old
i've never been married and what's wrong
with that i'm a career woman and i've
done very well and papa papa says why do
you have such a problem with that i
don't have a problem with that
but if you're 45 and you're single
and your best years are behind you as a
woman to find a good prospect
what the risk you took for just being a
courier person you're going to live a
very lonely life exactly and if you're
okay with that more power to you okay
but but this is the part this feminism
movement of living a lonely life it
takes a little bit while for people to
see what the side effects are you know
so for example steroids okay
do we know the negative and the positive
side effects of steroids well when it
first came out nobody knew right 80
years later guess what now we know what
it does to the liver we're learning
about what it does to this vaccine do we
know the side effects of the vaccine no
we don't know the back side but it's
going to take a decade or do to learn
what's going on okay we'll learn what's
going on with that in the military they
would give us shots we had no idea
what's going to happen but once we learn
then we have to adjust if we don't
adjust and it's too late we're screwed
that's the concern like
even with did you see what happened to
the nfl with jack del rio's comment he
made about january 6th and he talked did
you hear this on the question okay so
anyway so this guy makes a comment i
want to read this to you and and and
share with you why this is uh at the
same time with page seven if you want to
go to page seven so
uh papa papa where's it at there we go
nfl hall of famer ed reed urges con
commanders players this is washington
commanders players to take stand over
jack del rio's comments um
this is a bleacher report story pro
football hall of famer ed reed wants to
see washington commander's players speak
out against jack del rio for the
comments he made about january 6
insurrection at the capitol retweeted
saturday that the hundred thousand
dollar fine del rio was assessed is
nothing and player coaches by him need
to put your pants on and stand up to the
59 year old del rio initially caused the
stare
uh on monday when he responded to a
tweet about the hearing on the
insurrection in which he seemed to
equate the attack on the capital with
the public protest that occurred in the
summer of 2020 in response to
minneapolis police officer derek chauvin
murdering george floyd commanders head
coach ron rivera announced friday that
he got fined a hundred thousand dollars
after two minutes discussed this okay
the money will be donated to united
states capitol police memorial fund fine
okay
so
making that comparison
is a bad comparison to make
how many businesses were shut down
because of january 6
how many communities were turned upside
down with fire
africa i saw what this one man a grown
man in his 70s is saying why are you
doing this to me this is my business why
are you doing this to me i've been here
for 50 years
i can't afford to why are you doing this
to your own community what happened to
that uh protesting are we seeing
anything on that where's the hearing is
anybody being held accountable so so let
me tell you folks if now you're watching
and you're saying well pat you know
do you understand what january 6 i said
no no no no hang on remember
valuable currency is the ability to
reason
and to be able to reason we have to try
to control
our emotions which is very very hard to
do you just heard michael transparent
vulnerable saying i can't even look at
the man's face because it's so much
emotion involved when this thing
directly impacts your life
but you cannot tell me you're a
hypocrite
if you're willing to hold january 6
people accountable but you don't want to
hold the people accountable that
affected more people's lives
that affected more people's lives
negatively the blm protesting and the
founder of blm what happens to two years
later she's sitting on these three
houses really oh so so that's what you
support it no that's not what i
supported but that is what you supported
but that is what we drove
but that is what you were doing no but
that's not what i'm talking about no but
that's exactly what happened so
accountability needs to be held on both
sides absolutely if you're doing it on
both sides then we'll sit there and
we'll say what okay cool this is fine
did you see what happened with geico the
lady got a suit geico for 5.2 million
dollars and guy go out to pay this out
have you seen the story oh first of all
you got to cover this on the soft stocks
money so this is perfect story for you
so type in geico 5.2 million dollars std
okay
geico
may have to pay 5.2 million dollars to a
woman who got an std in an uninsured car
what she had sex go to usa today's story
not the npr go back and go to the usa
today just type back and type in usa
today usa today watch this
so this lady there it is okay
geico ordered to pay 5.2 million dollars
to a woman contracted std during sex in
an in an in short vehicle
let me get this straight
you had sex in an in a car
you got std from this guy can you zoom
in kai so we can read it as well because
kai is more interested in the article he
forgot about us so
in geico has to pay them 5.2 million
dollars
remington has to pay somebody 72 million
dollars because another person chose to
use the gun and remington has to pay 72
million dollars
geico's gonna have to pay 5.2 million
dollars because this woman sexually
transmitted disease in the insured
vehicle of her then boyfriend a state
appeal court ruled on tuesday the misery
court of appeals western district
published an opinion in favor of the
woman identified as uh mo who alleged
that she contracted hpv
during a sexual encounter in short
vehicles in 2017. shouldn't they sue the
boyfriend then
what that what the hell are we talking
about here
what are we talking who's winning today
who's no it's not it's not nobody is
whose argument is getting attention
today
this gets attention so we pay 5.2
million really oh and then what happened
to the streets all the riots no no no
they were doing they were just being
peaceful protesting no we had nicki
freed here and jedediah called her out
it was all over twitter because she says
well
you know jedidiah's like florida doesn't
have a problem with peaceful protesting
she says yeah peaceful protesting says
what are the kind of protesting is there
do you remember that moment what are the
kind of protesting is there
should we be able to do protesting will
we vandalize and we're okay with that so
so no that's okay so again the more and
more michael my opinion the more and
more they do what they do the more their
hypocrisy
is revealed and the more people sit
there and say i kind of supported that
but i don't support that it's kind of
weird like okay you know you go to uh uh
trump and his daughter
his daughter comes out and says what did
you read the story or no uh uh said she
agreed with bill barr's yeah
so she said it's on page six she says
um she says on page six let me go
through so ivanka trump says she
believed a.g bard that her father lost
2020 election this is bloomberg ivanka
trump the daughter of donald trump a
former white house advisor said she
accepted that there is no evidence of
fraud and that her father had lost 20 20
election a clip of her testimony was
played during the white house hearing on
january 6 on the capitol she was asking
that position that impression what
impression she had when the attorney
general william barr and trump and his
advisors there was uh no such fraud it
affected my perspective she said i
respect attorney general barr so i
accepted what he was saying now she's
not saying yes or no she's just saying i
respected the guy so i what
i uh uh uh respect what he's saying
trump comes back and says she wasn't
involved at that time okay
do you sit there and you agree with
everything trump does is right no no
absolutely not do you sit there and say
what everything everybody does is right
no but people have to start
reasoning again
the ability to reason has to become a
very valuable currency again
we've lost that recently we can sit
there and have a friendly debate
and you can say i agree with you i
disagree with you cool got it walk away
iran this was great awesome we reasoned
you won you made a good point i'm like
i'm smarter now i made a point like
that's a good point i didn't think about
that but we're not doing that anymore so
i think the people who are able to
reason
are going to come out
as leaders mcconaughey when he gave that
speech it's not the most popular speech
to give
you know a lot of people from nra is
like dude what are you talking about i
can't believe you said this
they don't like that speech but guess
what it did they got a couple of guys to
say
listen let's talk background check let's
do this listen reasonable yeah he's re
he's given a reasonable speech saying i
learned how to shoot a shotgun
in uvalde i grew up and they taught me
how to shoot in that city
i know like i'm all about this but i'm
not about this
and then we have to sit there and say ah
this [ __ ] just made a very good
argument
ah okay
all right good point fine
got it
at dinner this last week saturday with
two uh uh
big hollywood actors and we're having
dinner and i said you know where my
position changed when it came down to
health insurance health care what what
what what was it john q
you ever seen the movie john with denzel
washington was kind of like this kid's
trying to get a heart
at this point of the game listen man we
got a figure right away for this kid to
go it's quarter million dollars am i
saying let me pay for all your abortions
because you decide to have unprotected
sex i'm not for that but in that case
we're like the kid couldn't get that and
we learned so much about our system
do we just let this person die all right
do we just let this person go so but
that was a way where we watched we said
good argument i'm for so i think those
who reason will lead the future of
america that's why i hope so i'll tell
you when it comes to january 6 look i i
believe in peaceful protest if it's not
a peaceful protest it's not a protest
then it's vandalism whatever else it's
you call it what it is
my problem with this is that it's it's a
hypocritic
hearing
it's all one-sided they have one goal in
mind and that's to bury trump and it's
it's hypocrisy and i i just can't
support that
no i don't believe in it don't get me
wrong they shouldn't have done that it
was wrong whatever trump probably said
things to incite them even though it
wasn't direct but you know the flip side
of the coin where was the capitol police
where's the national guard that he
authorized to be there
nancy pelosi is a hypocrite so it's hard
for me to support anything that she
wants to do because i know it's in her
mind it's not for the benefit of people
she doesn't care nothing was going to
happen to her
you know it's the same like you know
with the supreme court if this was you
know this if this was a liberal supreme
court justice this would have been on
the front page of every newspaper would
be talked about you know the right would
be in blame they'd use it to high heaven
and i just can't stand that i i you just
i can't stand it and and again patrick
this is coming from a guy that lived
that was 20 years
a bad guy a criminal i mean i call it
the way it is you know
i just cannot i can't but do you think
they should not have these hearings
not at this point in time
when this country is reeling you know
when people are going to a gas station
put seven gallons of gas in their car in
california and paying 60
it's just over a quarter of a tank for
most people that's what you're worried
about january 6 at this point in time
when you know patrick named all the
things that people are struggling for i
mean look i live out in cal i live in a
pretty affluent neighborhood it's new uh
you know um
yeah newport beach but you know i see
what's going outside of that
i mean this is the time to have these
hearings are you that worried about
trump maybe that he's going to run
against or you want to bury him that's
the whole motivation for this so for me
it's just too much hypocrisy to support
and again i don't believe that they
should have stormed the capital 100
percent i don't believe that at all but
i don't believe what they're doing is
real and when you have a different
motivation you lose me on that
by by the way is it is there anybody
more far left on tv than rachel maddow
she's probably gonna be out there ryan
okay so she here's what she said rachel
maddow admits that trump had nothing to
do with the capital breach she said i
don't know if you saw this clip or not i
didn't yeah she said msmc rachel maddow
who inspires barbers around
she said this emphatically reminded the
fellow panelists and audience that
donald trump's rally was not repeat not
the starting point of the so-called
january 6th insurrection here's our
words just a key point that yes there
was a pro-trump rally at which the
president spoke and we can absolutely
talk about all the things the president
said there but the idea that the rally
is the thing that got
out of hand and that somehow resulted in
the breaching of the capital that rally
was very far from the capitol and the
people who as you say did the initial
breach that allowed everybody else to
come in
they never even went to the rally
and this is rachel rachel meadow that's
shocking we're not talking about tucker
you're not talking about hannity right
you're not talking about
santorum you're not you're talking about
you talk about maddow shocking rachel
maddow if there's a list of who is the
most hated person the person she hates
the most in her life it trump's on the
top of that leaders bulletin yeah he's
competing for the number one spot so
if but but you know what this gives me
this validates the point of even rachel
maddow's being forced to reason
she's cornered to reason because her
audience is saying i'm sick of your [ __ ]
i believed you you're pandering start
reasoning with me that's why i tune in
to you or else your eyeballs are going
away i'm not watching you anymore
eventually we as parents my kid
they'll come and say stuff to me right
and let's just say i try to use a parent
card the father card
and i'm being lazy about being a father
and i'm just kind of using my power and
then they come back and they cornered me
the reason you know what happens i get
upset but they're right all right so now
i'm kind of sitting there saying frickin
tico okay tico let's reason and and now
the reason i'm like i got it i gotta
give this guy this one he won this one
i'm not gonna tell him he won it but you
won this one here you go t go ahead and
do this right
these people who've been bullshitting
people
have to eventually reason or eyeballs go
away we watch the news for one reason we
want you to show us a way that we're not
thinking give us perspective and then
for us to say okay cool i got you i want
to tune in let me ask you this question
what is the reasoning what is the
mentality behind people
at the top
trying to interfere with a parent and
their child in their upbringing in their
sexuality in their morality
what do they think they can gain what
there's got to be some ulterior motive
some big picture that they think they're
going to create behind this
it's absurd to think
that you can get in between a parent and
a child with respect to their education
their sexuality their morality so what
is the big picture thought that they
have behind this because
these are the things that i can either
be so cynical
and and and come up with something or i
just can't figure it out i was at a
wayne hughes event at his house in
malibu
and they brought dennis prager there to
speak
and he said here's what the left is
doing the left is trying to make animals
and human beings equal
men and women equal gays and straights
equal okay
god and human equal parents and kids
equal
employer and employee equal
the risk taker and you know every
they're trying to make everything equal
right because they [ __ ] the person
that's the doer
they [ __ ] the father and the mother
that are paying the bills and funding
the house
they [ __ ] the man that brings the
security when has your woman ever
brought to security but so is that
so that they can become more dependent
upon them
no because it's the ultimate uh
machiavelli divide and conquer okay yeah
i'm saying but what's the what's the
reason behind it you said it machiavelli
because they want everybody to be
dependent upon them
no because the moment you are able to
create a division between two people
now you can turn the other person into
villain and you can win the other victim
over you can't ever recruit a doer
michael the hardest people to recruit
are doers
because doers don't need you let me say
this one more time
the hardest people to recruit
are doers who are responsible who get up
and work who pay their bills who are
doing everything right who have their
own ambitions their own dreams their own
vision on the life they want to build
you can't just recruit them with the
victimhood mentality stuff you can't
they they know that they're not as equal
as somebody ahead of them they know that
they understand that game but the victim
the other guys they're very easy to
recruit okay well you're talking about a
child
you know a five or six a seven-year-old
child
i mean that would they want to be able
to to give them vaccine without the
permission of their parents
what kind of
gall do they have do they think that
they can pull something like this off
you're a parent yeah what would you do
if somebody said hey i'll vaccinate your
kids i don't need your permission and
they try to alienate your child from you
i mean this is this is something that
would get people incensed and it's
happening i mean parents are going crazy
over this what's the what's the thought
behind that it's the same thing they
want to take control
over them
you know they want to divide and conquer
exactly so that they so that everybody
becomes dependent upon them yeah i mean
this has been going on for for a very
very long time this has been going on
for a very very long time you know you
go around american gangster the scene
denzel is standing there what are they
giving away in the city turkeys
why are they giving that away hey if we
give away turkeys you'll be quiet about
the fact that i'm selling blue magic in
the streets right okay hey these guys
are good guys i don't know what you're
talking about hey go to medellin i was
in uh bahamas last week
and you go to carlos leaders plane where
he crashed and i went snorkeling there
right great experience
and that was the airport uh
nelson what's it called
uh anyway something k no that's okay
nelson's k i think it's nelson maybe
it's a different word no no it's a
different word i believe anyways where
they would and then eventually they had
too much cocaine and they crashed it
right okay
go to medina and ask people about pablo
look how many people will say how much
they love them yeah
look how many people will be offended
how could you say something like that he
was a very good man why was he a good
man
because he he won votes through giving
things away for free same with no didn't
he not do that yeah yeah but but here's
the thing
this is this is our our teachers union
okay that has the support of the
government this is the government trying
to divide
a parent and a child
this is taught you just made my point
it's totally machiavellian that's what's
going on here and what's the ulterior
motive
it's control yeah
so that's what we're dealing with that's
why i wrote the book patrick and this is
what people have to understand this
there's more of a of a game plan here
from these people
uh on the top and we have to you know as
a republican
we have to fight against this we can't
allow this to happen peop parents are up
in an uproar and they should be they
shouldn't tolerate this kind of stuff
from i mean who are these people
we elect them and put them in office
they're you know we lost sight of things
look i spoke to the senate staff on the
anniversary of 9 11 at one point in time
and they took me on a tour for
everything i'm sure you've done that
before
these people don't want to give any of
that up i mean they don't even go out in
the rain you know they get you know
tunnels with things that they drive so i
have to get wet they don't want to give
it up
that's all there's they don't care they
don't want to give it up i believe in
term limits let them have two you throw
them the heck out after that let them go
get a job if they want to come back you
know four years later whatever but throw
them the heck out you cannot give people
power for that long because then it all
it's all about keeping control and power
and that's what's happening here
hegelian dialectic
has been around for a long time okay
create a problem blame him coming as the
hero it's a very basic format on what
they're using right create the problem
fabricate it you're the one that
fabricates it the politicians right
then come out and say i cannot believe
kai
created this problem with these searches
never show up on time it always goes to
the different website it's kai's fault
right and then come out and say but for
only 9.99 i have the solution
okay and we can sell the software but we
have to replace kai but i created the
problem right they've been doing this
for a long time the challenge becomes
when the american people are naive to it
and when you're naive to it and you pay
a price
i hate to say this to you but you
deserved it because you were blind you
were not willing to be studying on
what's going on in the marketplace and
why they're doing this they're going to
win over a lot of people michael they're
going to win over a lot of people until
they wake up
when i visited my mom we were having
lunch together she was making me pirachy
which if you haven't had piracha it's to
die for
she's a great cook but i said i said so
where are you at politics i said i'm i'm
no longer i'm no longer following this
establishment no because she was a
full-on card-carrying communist i'm no
longer there you kidding me i'm seeing
what some of these guys are doing
they've lost their minds
but you know it took her
70-some years to be at that point wow
unfortunately for some people it's too
late when you finally realize yeah what
the hell of a philosophy did i buy into
what was i thinking you know these
feminists who come out and they say man
i bought into feminism
and i'm 58 years old and single
and miserable what the hell did i
thought you were right
guess what i'm not equal to men
i'm not what they provide me i can
provide earlier i was talking about
security right
when have you
seen a guy date a girl or like oh my god
i'm with her because she provides me
security and protection
i've never heard it can you imagine like
i mean obviously sometimes you meet
certain people like she would whoop
anyone's tail you have cmma guys but for
the most part 99 of men and woman date
what's the s word i want security and
safety it's our job to do that we don't
rely on them to do it right okay so
anyways that's one part by the way the
one thing i do want to talk to you guys
about is the following so
they talked about uh let me just give a
shout out quickly to a couple of the
super chats so one is here fmas said why
are they not calling pelosi to testify
this will open up all the doors to the
truth uh dno
to national guard request uh another one
that we got is uh is uh by uh let me
read this next one here i got here this
other super chat is uh
jb well they're creating social chaos to
keep you distracted from the fleecing
the politicians are doing divide and
conquer no different than snowball from
the animal farm that's interesting we
just talked about that right uh uh tz
burton who's a member by the way shout
out to tz burton member the elephant in
the room is the corrupt media okay uh
lose
acosta pandolfi said my opinion is
january 6 was not an insurrection it was
american taxpayer protesting got a
national building funded by our taxpayer
dollar against the politicians
interesting way
of putting it right so but but i want to
talk to you about this one part
so
bill maher says why mass shootings
happen four reasons mental health easy
access smartphones movies and tv right
and he spends a lot of time talking
about movie tvs and video games you know
specifically movies where it's like the
shoot the heroes the what and he talks
about all these movies that are about
revenge revenge revenge revenge he gives
50 movie titles that have vengeance in
them revenge right and the bad guys
always get slaughtered by a automatic
weapon the good guy only gets hit in the
shoulder and you put a band-aid on it
and it's good to go on your safe right
okay so then stats comes out
and it says
22 weeks into the year
america has already seen
246
mass shootings
so my wife is sitting there she's like
babe is it kind of weird that all these
mass shootings are happening
so let me read this article from npr and
by the way npr is a we know who npr is
it's a very liberal tax funded media
company may 14th a racist attack at a
buffalo new york supermarket snatched
the lives of 10 people and three
more injured it was the deadliest mass
shooting of the year in the united
states for just over a week ten days
later gutman targeted a fourth grade
class at an elementary school in uvalde
texas killing 21 and during injuring 17
it was a deadliest school shooting in
america since sandy hook okay mass
shooting happened in the u.s with
depressing regular uh regulatory among
the at least 11 mass shootings over the
first weekend and june 14th uh june 14
people were shot near a nightclub in
chattanooga tennessee 14 people were
shot in a busy entertainment district in
philadelphia and eight were shot at
graduation party in summertown summerton
south carolina it follows a shooting at
a hospital in tussle oklahoma tulsa
oklahoma and the weekend of violence the
previous week sunday is day 156 of the
year the country has already experienced
at least 246 mass shootings so far at
least 246 in just 22 weeks the average
is out to be 11 a week the tally comes
over the gun violence archive the
independent data collection organization
etc etc right let's talk about okay
so
here's what i thought about i said
whatever we see we want to become
why do so many kids become athletes
because that's what we watch if sports
wasn't on tv
would kids become professional athletes
or would they just do it for
entertainment if if we didn't have
a
you know a
tv to watch michael play like mike
i want to be like mike right or mark
maguire baseball derby with you know
sammy sosa or barry bonds or wayne
gretzky or roger clements or you know
thurman thomas or barry sanders or
emmett smith or bring it to today you
know judge yeah all the aaron judge
who's just killing it on track to he
wants his 400 million dollar contract so
all these things you're saying i want to
be like that guy one day i want to be
like that guy one day why because it's
repetitive and we turn him into heroes
and it's repetitive okay
every
time i turn to
anything on the news another mass
shooting another mass shooting another
mass shooting another mass shooting
another mass shooting another mass
shooting
it's a form of recognition
and it's constant recognition
recognition recognition then anger anger
anger anger recognition recognition
recognition anger anger anger anger
anger
so kid is sitting there who's already
angry
at a video game he played girl that
broke up with him
whatever he's going through mom didn't
tell him his love he loves him being bad
he left them being bullied in school
which is happening left and right
all this stuff is going on he's saying
you know what it's not fair
it's not fair and he goes out there and
does something
so
to everybody that's kind of like
wondering maybe i'm not alone on this
are you also wondering why we're having
so many mass shootings is this almost
needed for them to say see we need guns
you see we need guns you see we need
guns see we need guns
my concern is who are we recognizing
who we recognizing
and are we wanting these people also
become heroes and kids are like i'm
gonna go be hero dude you're not
becoming a hero
by doing what you're doing you're
ruining your life
by doing this
there's no benefit to you doing this
part but
and then the other side becomes with the
media smartphones easy access mental
health okay mental health
partially that's on
these pharmaceutical companies you got
the video games that you can talk about
nobody wants to talk about hip hop rap i
grew up listening to a pop rap hit em up
all this stuff dmx all this stuff it's a
lot of anger it's a lot of hatred oh i
can't believe you're doing that you're
becoming like these are no i'm not i'm
just telling you affirmations has power
right
but there's a form of recognition people
want to be stars today and this is an
opportunity for me to get my you know 15
seconds of fame or whatever it is right
but why do you think we're having such a
surge
in mass shootings right now 246 for the
year and it's only june why do you think
we're having such a surge of mass
shooting i are you
well look i i you i did see that thing
with bill maher by the way bill maher's
probably one of the more reasonable
necessary voices in america today
because he's not just calling out again
this goes back to my initial point when
trump's not there you don't have the
scapegoat anymore you have to call out
real issues
but
the gun situation to your point it's not
just one thing it is mental health
michael touched on it i don't think 18
year old kids should just go in there no
background check boom they have a gun i
think it should be raised to 21. i think
when you're 16 17 18 you're in the
middle of high school you can't get laid
girls won't pay attention to you you're
bullied you're picked on you're watching
movies all these movies that you're
playing games call of duty this that
there's social media bullying there's so
much stuff happening to you when you're
16 17 18 your body's going through
different things transition
and you're angry you're [ __ ] pissed
at the world you know i remember being a
16 year old kid 18 year old kid i would
fight with my parents every day you're
just you're in such a negative state of
mind it's a toxic environment and now
you have access to a gun
i'm sorry i mean things need to be done
we talked about um
the easy access to guns but mental
health look do you think people in the
united states are crazier than
everywhere else in the world
i think we have an equal amount of crazy
people in the united states as we do in
europe as they do in australia as they
do in canada crazy is crazy i don't
think usa is crazier but when you
add on everything else you touched on
with on top of mental health it's a
recipe for disaster and it's
look at the end of the day
enough's enough but why increase in mass
shooting i don't know if there is i mean
maybe there but i just feel like the
media sensationalizes everything i think
it people are
completely within their right to be fed
up with media and media
you know whether it's trump whether it's
mass shootings whether it's politics
whether it's any like they're going to
cover the event that gets eyeballs so me
you know
as sad as it is
people tune in to you all day people
tune in to what's going on at buffalo
people tune into when a synagogue gets
shot up people tune in to when
someone walks into a church starts
shooting up church-goers it's horrible
but the media goes by eyeballs and like
you said affirmation has power and what
you show on the media is a real thing so
i don't know if there's more mass
shootings now or if they're just
covering it more i know you just said
the stats
but
something needs to get done and this is
the first step in the strategy that what
the what the senators are doing and keep
in mind it takes in the house i think
it's just a majority vote
and then the senate i think you need 60
votes so we're not even anywhere close
yet but i think the country is yearning
to do freaking something to sit back and
be like hey a good guy with a gun stops
a bad guy a gun well it didn't really
work in your vault day did it because
the [ __ ] cop stood outside the
classroom for what 45 minutes
with a gun but but that but then but
that doesn't
fix it the the the changes they make
doesn't fix that
not everything
not everything's gonna fix an individual
scenario but i think we're we're talking
in a macro perspective for the united
states right things need to get done you
touch on opioids mental health is a
major thing okay
like you said rap hip-hop to an even
larger extent
the the video game gun culture movies
you know the good guy like you said the
bad guy gets his head blown off the good
guy gets shot in the shoulder keeps
carrying on
all these things add up to what's going
on in america today i'm going to tell
you why i don't think it can be fixed
and it's because of the mindset of the
country right now and i'll give you my
experience i spent eight years in prison
and during those years i spoke to a lot
of young kids that came into the system
21 22 years old mandatory minimum drug
census they get 20 years they're
spending 17 and a half because no more
parole in the federal system
you can write the same script for every
single one of them fatherless home
mom young trying to do her best she's
got her own problems can't raise the kid
properly he's got no guidance gets on
the street you know gets with the local
bank gang banger drug dealer before you
know it they're in prison no guidance
whatsoever
right
and that's the trend give these kids
contraceptives when they're you know in
in high school let them go out and have
sex all they want so they can bring kids
into this world
that don't have a father and don't have
a stable home
now now they have their cell phones i
agree with bill maher you can get
netflix on your cell phone now it's not
like you have to go to movies anymore
go look at netflix action adventures
shoot them up shoot them up shoot them
up all low budget films all about action
and adventure that's what these kids are
watching it's all about guns guns guns
guns that's the the kind of product that
they're putting out there now especially
after the pandemic so they're seeing all
of this stuff they got no guidance in
the house nothing at home
emotional problems yeah because so many
of them are on drugs that brings you an
emotional issue right away you're not in
your right mind when you're doing this
stuff it's a deadly lethal com a
combination of of things that are taking
place and there's no cure at this moment
because nobody's willing to go back now
i i will offend people i don't know why
women are offended when you tell them
your child doesn't have a father why is
that offensive to you ladies do you want
to bring this kid up by yourself you
don't want help
i'm a father i want all the help i can
get with my kids you know and the right
kind of help i want my wife there when i
can't perform she can when i can't
reason with them she can but people get
offended by this now you're offending
women if you say you know you should
have two parents in the home
so how is this going to turn around
i don't think it is
i i know it sounds like i have a
pessimistic view because i'm being
realistic this has been my experience
and i i don't
you know unfortunately in life so often
i mean it happened in me i had to i had
to sink to the depths before i made a
transformation in my life you know i had
it had to hit me because at one point in
time i thought i was in control i
thought i can do everything until boom
you know i'm in a six by eight cell
thinking i'm gonna spend the rest of my
life there and then wow this is a real
problem i'm in trouble here and i
started to look like like patrick said
then you start to really look at things
what's going on here for me fortunately
it wasn't too late so
what's going to happen here before
people say okay enough we got to get
back to reality you know i'll tell you
this too and this shouldn't be offensive
as a matter of faith you can't push god
you can't push god out of everything
you know you can't unless you unless you
have a clear answer as to why we're here
and there is no god you have to at least
consider him you can't push him out of
everything and that's happening here in
this there's no alternative what's the
alternative a real documented
evidence-bound backed alternative to god
give it to me and then maybe we can look
that way but there is none so people are
pushing god out
and and it's showing
and listen as a christian i'm telling
you it's biblical it's prophetic you
know you don't you don't want to i don't
want to get there right now because i
don't think this is the appropriate time
for it but i see what's happening but
michael maybe
what you said is very powerful and i'll
tell you why like what what hit me
is maybe your story is a metaphor of
what needs to happen to america because
you said you know you were gangster
you're a racketeer you ended up in jail
for eight years could have been longer
you had to look at yourself in the
mirror and say am i going to spend the
rest of my life in this cell and you had
to hit rock bottom before you had to
turn your life around which you have
rightfully so i know but maybe that's
what needs to happen to america right
what would that be adam what what
catastrophic thing would happen to would
have to happen to this country until we
say wait a second
we need
we got to go back to the roots we have
to have a family here i think it's a
culmination of everything that's
happening right now okay kids our kids
are being killed off in drugs exactly
in droves this is this is you know what
i think it's the worst problem we're
facing in this country it's an epidemic
and people are not paying attention to
it those that are suffering over it and
there's so many of them if you think a
hundred thousand kids a hundred thousand
people between the ages of 24 and 45 how
many families has that affected
100 000 yeah
we're talking a lot of people are
affected by this and it hasn't stopped
it's continuing it's probably getting
worse
so what catastrophic event has to happen
before we realize hey this is real
problem here
how do you reverse that i don't have the
answer i don't know
because the mentality now that's why i
get so incensed with people on the left
you see this stuff happening
you're pandering to criminals you're at
the expense of legitimate hard-working
citizens
you're doing all these things that it
you know bible says there's going to be
a time when good is bad and bad is good
it's happening right now
and i don't know how you reverse that
but i think
at the end of the day common sense needs
to win out i mean everything you touched
you talked about is absolutely accurate
and i don't have kids so i'm not i don't
have those same exact worries that pat
has every single day with a one-year-old
a five-year-old
eight-year-old and ten-year-old right i
mean i don't have those exact same words
it's scary out there but still i'm sure
pat would would agree that the future
does look bright but sometimes it
becomes you know what is it it gets
darker before it becomes light i think
we're going through a very dark time in
america right now and i think it's going
to get uglier i think a recession as pat
talks about is upon us
but
you know
mcconnell nancy pelosi the you know the
the
octogenarians out there the
80-somethings are out who are running
this country i think it's time for them
to go and i think a new leadership needs
to take place that's why i'm so excited
to vote for someone like a ron desantis
i think a new fresh perspective needs to
reach america the same old same old that
we've been doing for decades
is not going to work anymore but here's
my thinking and patrick maybe you can
because i know how you think and you too
adam
what kind of catastrophic event has to
occur
before we get back to the roots of what
we're really supposed to live like we're
parents you'll you'll experience maybe
this one day
we understand what it takes to raise
kids it's not easy it's difficult even
under the best of conditions it's a hard
job it's work and we're raising a person
to go out into the world look you know
i'm a fr i will not allow my daughter to
go into los angeles alone i said you
can't go
dad you can't go period i am not going
to have you there worrying that you're
going to get out of the car or you're in
a parking lot and somebody is scoping
you out i tell you you got pepper spray
you walk into a parking lot you do what
i do okay you look all around you you
make sure everything you know you know
everything around you she's dead you're
getting me nervous so i want you nervous
because these things are happening right
now and i don't want you to be that
statistic and i don't want to go through
that i'm being selfish too because she
listens to you well she does because i i
put fear in her in that way i said look
this is the world we live in you know
it's reality
okay you go out you're in a parking lot
i'm hearing i mean
in new york they're going up to people
and throwing them on the tracks
i lived in that city i never saw things
like that
i mean this is a crazy even crime riddle
new york in the late 70s early 80s yeah
in the 70s it was pretty bad back then
right it was someone like giuliani had
to come in and clean it up it was well
it was very bad back then yes
honestly and you know what people can
say what they want about giuliani he
prosecuted me wanted to put me away for
the rest of my life and i like the guy
because he cleaned up my city
i mean it and he wrote the form
even before that let me let me ask a
question how long do you think it should
take from
a person to walk into a gun store
buy a semi-automatic weapon with a
magazine and bullets how long do you
think it should take
a thorough background check whatever
that takes and i you know i'm not expert
in that but i think a thorough back
chair listen
i mean come on kid walks in at 22 years
old where's your mom and dad
you're 21 where's your mother and father
how did you grow up i want to know about
this kid
because again he's got his phone he's
who knows what the situation is with him
he's irresponsible to begin with
i mean my son you know had two two duis
before he was 23 24 years old i wouldn't
put a gun in his hands and i know he
wouldn't shoot anybody he's not that
type of kid but still you were
irresponsible enough to get a dui
you know
how long do you think it should take how
long things should take weeks
oh really yes seriously yes and you're a
conservative saying i am how long do you
think you should take
well not a day
whatever's
whatever they're able to pass that's
longer than whatever the current okay
can you can you this this is what i did
four years four and a half years ago
five years ago
in dallas uh can you can you bring that
up kai just make the video bigger and i
want to see if you can see this okay
we're at the store right now we're about
to walk in to buy a semi-automatic
weapon let's see how long it takes by
the way i'm in the city of
plano texas mario can you give me your
phone i want to show exactly what time
it is
it is monday march 26th
11 40 am okay
terrible comparison but let's go see how
long it takes us to buy this
semi-automatic weapon
watch this
all right here's your seat here
and now
i'm walking out
okay mario can you open this all right
so here's
our weapon
here's
the magazine that by the way this
magazine is not a line in the state of
california
this is a time 11 59. so as you can see
you can pause it 19 minutes
what do you think about that
i think it's wrong
i you know it's a semi-automatic weapon
yeah 19 minutes to me
so okay when i talk to uh uh uh i'm
conflicted with this so i like the
banter going back and forth so for me on
the one side they're like pat what if we
the the government turns against and
they they're they're coming after you
don't you want to be able to have the
citizens have access to go get a gun
okay all right fine so that's your fear
no it's a right it's an alien you know
it's a right of mind that's in the
constitution second amendment they can't
take it away from me fine
got it okay but 19 minutes you want the
average person to get 90 yeah
i said so how long does a prescription
drug background check take
to see what you're on okay
i i if you want to buy a pistol
okay fine maybe let's make the argument
that you can buy the pistol you want to
get an m16 it's not a it's not an
automatic weapon it's a semi it's a big
difference okay fine no problem
but should you have access to you know
all the stuff that to be able to get it
that quickly why not do why not take a
week why not take two weeks no but if
something happens we have to okay
so no matter where i'm going with this
you get to a point you're like
i don't know
if i want just anybody off the street to
be able to go get this
there's got to be something where i if
you're on a certain medication we're
talking mental health i'm not
comfortable i agree you know i'm just
not comfortable now
to the the guy in uvalde that did what
he did his background was clear he
didn't have any issues he was 18 years
old when he bought it and then while he
didn't do you know he bought it and he
went and did it he didn't do the next
day was weeks later after he bought it
so that still would have allowed him to
go do what he did because
even if you change it to two weeks that
still doesn't so again you go back and
forth with this debate to say how many
of these 246 mass shootings would have
been eliminated based on changing the
laws to ages and you come down to only
five percent so even with the new you
understand what i'm saying so even with
all the new things let's make it 21
let's make it 18 let's make even with
that less than 5
of those could have been eliminated
so your 246 becomes what 230
okay whatever the number is 2 30 2 30.
so yes it may be a good publicity stunt
to do this but i'm looking for real
solutions what is the real solution
on what to do with this part you talk
about single-family households america
is the the number one country in the
world for the most single parents look
at this percent this is from pew
research pew research is not fox or uh
or cnn can you make it a little bit
closer kai zoom in a little bit more so
we can see that yeah so according to
peer research the us has the highest
rate of single parenting in the world in
2018 almost a quarter of u.s children
under the age of 18 lived in a household
with a single parent and no other adult
present other than adult children being
a single parent predominantly affects
mothers around the world the u.s around
20 children with their mothers are on
five percent i mean go go up to show the
statistic
go up to show the statistics 49 of what
is that 49 and 20 49 of black children
in the u.s lived with one parent
as did 28 of hispanic kids and 21 of
white kids go show up look at that chart
right there adam look at that
this is not a leaders bulletin you want
to be number one in
so again even though i did that social
experiment that we did four or five
years ago
that would have still only prevented
five to ten percent of it
so what is the solution to this you know
is this just something for people to
change past some lawsuits say well look
at this we got a victory we passed this
dude you're still going to have 230 of
those shootings yeah but it goes back to
exactly what i said it's not the one
solution alone is not raising the age
limit and doing a background check
that's not the the one solution the
solution i mean what do you do do you
call child services and go to the kid's
house and talk to his mother and his
grandmother whoever he was living with
see if he has a
you know i mean how far
how far of a background search do you do
on someone that's why i think you've got
to raise the age limit that's number one
a kid at 18 years old should not have
you know a weapon like that what is he
doing what has he got it for tell me why
you could go and buy a gun that quickly
but it's going to take you three more
years to go sit down at your local pub
and legitimately buy a beer how does
that make any sense it makes no sense
and there's certain states where i think
you need to be 21 to even just buy some
marijuana
yes look
do i agree that the second amendment
should exist and we should americans
should be able to have guns yes it's
second amendment like no matter what you
say it is the second amendment
but nowhere in the second amendment does
it say you should be able to get a gun
in less than 10 minutes in a day right
it doesn't say that
so
the the
the straw man of like well they're going
to come take my guns
i got to be able to protect myself from
the government it's like really you
think that you're going to
protect yourself from the government
come the swat team comes after you okay
best of luck
but there needs to be some some
regulations and some rules around what
i'm saying to you is
even if we follow all the logic which
makes sense it's still only going to be
five percent of it would have been
prevented
so
even if you're 18 to 21 fine i i can go
there and say you want you don't trust
me to drink alcohol you trust me with a
gun that's an easy three second argument
so they're gonna have to come up well
yeah but the military's 18. yeah but
even in the military i didn't sleep with
my gun yeah i always had to turn in my
gun after i'm done shooting
congratulations you're in the military
you're allowed to use the gun and if
you're not in the military you've got to
wait three months but even in the
military the gun is not with you it goes
back in the safe that you have to sign
in and sign out but all i'm saying to
you is
even if we take your approach
on what you're saying
even if we do all these things that
mcconnell is saying still only going to
say five percent of them but pat
even if it saves five percent that's x
amount of lives but but you're saving
which you know what don't no i i want to
push the limit to challenges to think
about a better permanent solution i
agree to me
to me this is a systemic issue this is a
education this is a all-around cultural
issue of who we admire and who we turn
into heroes
that's the issue
kids want to become a hero kids
everybody no matter how old you are what
color you are
what level of education you have
everybody wants to be somebody in life
so that somebody isn't being the next
great basketball player
everybody wants to leave a legacy behind
everybody does from the smallest
ambitious person to the most ambitious
person everybody wants to leave some
kind
this this has to be presented at this is
not a way to be a hero
here's why
parents need more training
marriages need to be more
faith values principles i don't care if
you're seven day
jehovah
christian judaism catholic i don't care
what you're practicing go
to somewhere where they're you know
selling
forgiveness you know like the messaging
of forgiveness you take all everything
with faith take the individual out take
abraham out take el ron hubbard out take
jesus out take moses out take take all
these people out right keep the
personality i don't think he's a real
guy
fine take all that stuff out
write a summary on the bible write a
summary on you know old testament write
a summary
and like bullet points what are they
teaching us
forgive your this neighbor this you know
adultery this
wife this you know with friends this is
okay
mother this the protect your nuts
just put those values and principles
what's wrong with that
the problem to me isn't freaking
increasing the age the problem to me is
we are no longer selling the values and
principles that made america such a
great country where people around the
world wanted to come and raise their
families here
that's the permanent problem adam and i
think that's what we're having issues
with when's the last time you saw
somebody like even
when's the last time you saw somebody on
fox or or msnbc or cnn just praying
when's the last time say hey i just want
to do a prayer can we do prayer here's
what i want to pray and you pray for
peace you pray for forgiveness you pray
for you know improvement you pray for
love you pray you i again i don't this
is boring stuff
none of us wanted to hear this stuff
from our parents when we were kids none
of us wanted to hear but guess what
those who did benefited from it those
who didn't didn't benefit from it
so that's what i'm saying where i'm not
looking for like hey let's just pass
it's only going to five percent but i
think you're what you're saying is you
there needs to be some action steps here
yeah because thoughts and prayers alone
aren't going to get this no no but
patrick just he just confirmed my
argument i'm going to tell you something
very personal
my mother got pregnant when i was fit
when she was 15 years old i was born
when she was 16 years old
my grandmother
because we lived in an italian
neighborhood in brooklyn was so
embarrassed that my mother had a child
out of wedlock that she wanted my mother
to abort me my grandmother did
which was not uncommon back then you
didn't have a child out of wedlock
my grandmother forced my mother and this
is the story my mother told me patrick
and i can reveal it now
um that she got pregnant with my father
sonny but my father was married at that
time okay he couldn't get a divorce
because divorces weren't allowed at that
time in the mob wasn't allowed to do it
my grandmother forced my mother to marry
someone just so that it would appear
that she was married when i was born
right
the point being is the the morality back
then you didn't have a child out of
wedlock it was the wrong thing to do you
jus you just said it
teach the parents what parents
there's usually one person
if you do a study on all of these kids
and i think i think i read something i'm
not sure but most of these mass
shootings were were done by kids that
were between the ages of 20 and 26
something like that i'm not positive but
i think that's what i heard okay if you
go into the background of these kids i
guarantee you're going to see it as a
messed up family or no family life at
all
so that's the root of the problem how do
you change that when you're giving
contraceptives to kids when they're 9 10
12 or whatever it is you know in high
school without the parents knowledge
it's okay you don't even have to ask so
these kids are having sex oh it's no
problem now go get an abortion so you
abort you know 300 000 babies a year
through planned parenthood but this is
all okay it's a breakdown in morality so
yes i agree with you you know maybe you
save five percent but you got to do
something
it's almost like you're working
backwards
yeah you're right but you're almost like
working backwards i don't think so i
don't think so like for example like i i
again
guys please push back like if you if i
have a leak in my argument
identified so for example like you know
how they're saying well you know let's
let's cancel school debt
no i don't think that's the right but
we're making progress no we're not why
not because
college twitch inflation has increased
200 in the last 40 some years college
tuition has increased 1200 percent
education hasn't improved a thousand
percent no
what about we lower tuition
okay
your salary in the last four years has
only gone from twenty two thousand
dollars to forty some thousand dollars
it's only gone up 120 130 percent
college has gone up 200 percent no
before you cancel college yet i'm for it
let's cancel college tuition
a day after
we force these universities that are the
big capitalists to decrease their
tuition by 80 percent why don't we do
that i'm for it why don't you take away
their tax exempt stuff yeah why don't we
do that so why don't we take away their
taxes why should they be if you want to
take away their tax exempt do that then
the next day i'm all in for cancelling
all the school debt i agree i'm with
that no no no no no we can't do that
because you don't want to hold the
institutions that give you that
certificate that for 40 years you've
been bragging about how big of a deal
that piece of paper is no no
you have to say that because you're part
of that gang so so for me when we're
talking about well like levick just
commented right armenian guy and he says
uh uh he says as in armenia we mourn on
april 24 due to government in 1908 that
took away our guns from people then
killed one and a half million armenians
750 000 assyrians 500 000 greeks that's
why we need firearms and lots of them
levik i'm saying to you i want more
people to be trained i would love a
hundred percent of americans to be
trained on how to use guns who are not
on medication who are not dealing with
mental health who have a good background
in the past that's been cleared up i'm
okay with them but i don't want anybody
off the street to be able to go by
within five minutes i don't want that
but that still doesn't solve the issue
to me the issue is
like
you know you know like
we look up to people
and naturally whoever you hang around
you're gonna pick up some other habits
very few people have a strong enough of
a personality that they can be around a
lot of bad people and still not do
anything
very few i was around a lot of drugs
never liked drugs
never i tried a few them i'm like i just
don't like them right
but i was around it my best friend died
because he started off with cigarettes
then weed alcohol and he died on vicodin
right okay so one of our friends just
committed suicide this week
heartbreaking story i got out of nowhere
like a guy i've been doing business for
two or 12 years more all in on the phone
is just emotional mario's and crying
anyways this guy took his life he's got
a daughter what is he going through
so we need a leader that's
giving the message of
listen man
your mom and dad you guys disagree with
you when it comes down to politics your
last name matters your heritage matters
unite one of my guys one time called me
and he says let me tell you what my
sister's doing and let me tell my
brother's doing i said listen bro hey
whatever your brother's doing whatever
your sister's doing it's you only got
one blood
figure it out make it work unite and
disagree it's fine but figure out a way
to make it work you only got a couple
sisters i'm not telling you go hang out
and buy into their philosophy but it's
your blood have some respect for your
own family okay got it that makes sense
we're not giving messages like that
messages isn't about
somebody from the top needs to re-inject
the right morals values and principles
that gets us to make better decisions
and we say that is somebody i admire
our hero making machine today is the
biggest problem and it sucks we're
turning the wrong people into heroes
patrick as soon as that person comes out
the other side kills him and there's
such a debate over it so no problem it's
no problem it's going to happen
it's going to happen but it's but you
don't need to listen
i learned a long time ago i learned a
long time ago because i lost one of the
guys that uh you know i looked up to a
lot and then there was a falling out
with this person and i this is in the
early 2000s and he went one side i went
once i'm like oh my god without this
person i can never make it okay broke my
heart and this relationship was lost
because you know he wanted me to do
certain things i just didn't want to do
but i admired him a lot okay this isn't
a business deal that we're doing i
didn't want to do what he wanted to do
with the business side
so i said man without him i can never
make it
that's the phase i went from 20 to 23
years old i think there's no way i can
make it without this guy there's no way
i can make it without this guy there's
no i can make without this guy
and then you get bigger bigger bigger
bigger bigger you're like
yeah my values didn't match up with him
you need the right people when you find
them lock them and especially the people
that believe in you and their strong
value principles
but you don't need everybody
you need you don't need everybody to
come you we don't need to convert
everybody into living a better life we
just need more
one percent if you convert that one
percent will impact
uh eighty percent you need one person
whose messaging inspires people you
don't need everybody's messaging to
inspire you only need one person that
makes an argument it didn't take fifty
matthew mcconaughey's it took one
matthew mcconaughey where like all right
you don't need a thousand people that
are giving a message that makes sense
you need one person for a person to say
for thousands of to say
jordan peterson is one man how many has
he inspired you you got a lot of people
that are like you know what he kind of
makes sense you gotta look at you how
many people you think you
and you don't even know it how many
people you think you've indirectly
encouraged to not go live that life well
i hear a lot of that on a daily basis oh
yes but not the people you hear forget
about the people you hear
right you're right how many that you
don't hear
that's the real number it's not the
people that come up to us it's the
person that's in
you know in portugal that watches you
that you will never meet this man right
and he was about to take someone's life
and he was about to go in a different
direction all of a sudden well if
michael's going to say that and he lived
that life and he said it's not worth it
i'm not going to do it so i don't think
it's winning everyone over we never will
we never have but i think that one
percent of inspiration of the leaders
rising up to start talking about the
right morals values and principles
i think we're going to see it turn so
yeah even though i did that social
experiment when i got those guns i'm
like
yeah that's still not going to do
anything even to 5 5 to 10 is going to
be impacted i think we need to go back
to being better at developing leaders i
think we need to go back to talking
about the right values and principles i
think we need to readjust who we turn
into heroes and i think if we do that's
going to inspire the right amount of
people but it goes back to what we said
or what i said earlier
there's got to be some catastrophic
event you know what you're describing i
guarantee christians that i think this
you're describing the antichrist
the guy that's going to come and is
going to unite the world unfortunately
that's the wrong person that we want
because it's misleading obviously but
that's the person you're describing i
think
unless there is some kind of
catastrophic event that really changes
the mindset and said this is not working
we're really going down the rabbit hole
we're going in a bad place i don't know
how you reverse it patrick i don't
i don't when i said you're starting
backwards you know you're working
backwards with you know these gun
control things i i think it's it's a
it's a rational
step to take
because kids are irresponsible at 18
years old even under the best of
circumstances most of the times they are
raise the limit to 21. what are they
needed at 18 for any i'm trying to think
what do you need it for what are you
gonna do with it oh just because i'm an
american that's my freedom well you know
what we can raise the age limit you
can't drink until you're 21 you don't
buy a gun until you're 21. i don't i
think that again people say okay that's
rational we can do it it makes sense but
there's more of an issue there there's
more of an issue and to me it all goes
down the root of the problem is the
breakup of the family in this people
kids just don't get the right training
you know in this life you know this
patrick better than anybody and so
we are who we are accountable to
when i was on the street i was
accountable to my oath i was accountable
to my boss and i was a criminal as a
result of that that's my accountability
when i left that life i became
accountable to my my god my wife my kids
don't want to make a mistake stay on the
right path
so
these young kids they don't have
accountability in the right place and
they're never going to get it you know i
use mike tyson as a perfect example this
kid had more arrests than half the mob
did before he was 12 years old until he
meets customarto
and it was a life-changing experience
for him he never had anything if you
talk to him cuss was like a god to him
why because you gave him proper training
that you're supposed to get in your
house
they're not getting it
and you know it's i don't see how you
reverse this
i i just don't see unless some kind and
i don't know what that event is i don't
i don't know what it could be i don't
have the solution but something has got
to happen to make people say hey well
you just validated my point with cuss
you just validated the point with cuss
it took one person cuss i'm not talking
about the next ronald reagan we're
waiting for the next billy graham or
jesus
i'm talking about we need more cusses
yes that's what i mean
where do they come they they're in the
house where they where do you find them
well no what i'm saying to you is we
need to turn them into heroes
the hero making machine is the problem
because we don't know them those stories
need to be told like the teacher that
plays the role of a father figure for a
kid who was a nobody and the kid ends up
becoming a great citizen where is that
story that's the story we need to tell
not hey this kid's a transgender let's
tell this what do you talk like what
what who are you trying to inspire with
that
what do you what do you what are you
doing with that part that's keep it to
yourself if that's what you want to do
fine we don't say hey here's this family
this is how they like to sexually please
each other this is the position they use
keep it to yourself whatever you want to
do with that part you don't need to
bring that to my life i know but you see
you you're teaching your kids that
that's the kind of person they have to
look up to because you're teaching them
that
they look up to you and they look up to
that person because you're showing them
that what about the kid in the house
that has nobody to tell them this is who
you should be looking at but but i'm
from a broken family i'm coming from a
divorced family it was and my dad was a
99 cent my mom went back to iran because
he ran out of money i had another man
that i looked up to luther al jose that
just passed away two years ago and i
you know my dad played a role of hey
values values values values values he he
made me as a man but i needed an
inspiration for somebody to say well
maybe when that can be successful even
though i got no grades going for myself
i got nothing going for myself i i think
but how much of an impact did your dad
have on you 100 that's it yeah 100
that's it 100
uh you know no question about it but
even if we don't
we can have people that set the tone
with what the right values and
principles are to live by i think this
issue is more internal than it looks and
the thing about taking it from 18 to 21
i'll put the math brain on
listen when did we decide that the guns
are at 18 years old kai what was the age
that they decided on 18 years old
what was the age well when did when did
they decide and math has got to be 18
years old your age has got to be 18
years old so every conservative
nra card carrying member you're not
gonna like what i'm gonna tell you but
i'm gonna bring the math hat on okay and
think like an actuary 1968 what was the
life expectancy in 1968
six months
okay let's see here 1960 life expectancy
okay
uh 1968 life expectancy is what what is
it
71 73 okay uh no the previous 70 and 0.2
19. okay so 70.2 what's today's life
expectancy okay so seventy point two was
then life expectancy today
is what go big a little bit bigger
78.7 okay 78.7 is today what is that
eight years 1968 18 8 years 26 that's
called math
so the 18 years old of 1968 is 26 years
old today that's what an actuary would
do we're living longer today so when
you're arguing about 18 years old we're
living a longer life anyways so even 21
that means you have five additional
euros than you would have had in 1968.
if a liberal sees what i just said they
can run with this and a liberal
economist can put this up and make the
argument people gonna that does kind of
make sense do you understand what i just
said right there or no i'm just doing a
math site logically like it or don't
like it just logically we can do that if
we really don't want it to go that route
anyway but the strong argument against
that is exactly what adam said yeah then
why should you be why should you not
have to wait till 21 to drink if you can
hold a gun yeah okay an assault weapon
why should you have to wait till
twenty-five dollars i don't i don't
disagree with that part i don't disagree
with that part
all i'm saying is all i'm saying is for
me
i want
to find a long-term solution rather than
another band-aid that's what i want to
put can you go to my twitter kai we'll
finish with this if you can go to
twitter just go to twitter real quick
on twitter and go to my last tweet
whatever it is just go to my live go
call the lore that's okay that's us
uh go little lord lord lalor
is that one right okay right uh
however the one that says however go a
little lower
go the lower kai go above it okay go
above it because it's two tweets above
it right okay and make it zoom in a
little bit okay so check this out
so tracking inflation since january of
2021 january 2020 when inflation was 1.4
percent
march 2021 two months later 2.6 we gave
the 1.9 trillion dollar covered relief
july 2021 six months set at 5.4 demps
proposed 3.9 trillion dollar budget plan
november 2021 it goes from 1.4 to 6.8
uh biden signs one trillion
infrastructure package march 2022 7.9
april 2022 8.3 may 2022 8.6 bad policies
have consequences printing money has
consequences here's my concern what both
sides of the aisle have done to delay
the time bomb that the market is
experiences behind us there's nothing
that can be done about the past to blame
however here's the last part
when we officially go into recession the
next few weeks let's not bring back
quantitative easing to delay the pain
for another 10 more years let the
economy naturally rebuild itself it'll
be painful for those who constantly get
bailed out but it'll serve the next
generation my interest is permanent
solutions
that's my interest so we're talking
about what we're talking about these gun
laws none of these are temp permanent
solutions they're all permanent they're
all temporary how much resistance is
going to be uh there not to you
are you kidding me to get re-elected
they're going to do a two-track exam
when recession comes they're going to do
another two trillion dollars exactly and
guess what people are going to vote for
to get another two trillion dollars but
we have to let some of these guys go out
of business
uh uh price needs to be paid
unfortunately we don't want any of it we
keep delaying the pain for the next
generation anyways uh gang if you
enjoyed today's podcast give it a thumbs
up subscribe to the channel and go buy
the book if you haven't yet we're going
to put the link below to the book we got
one last thing that i want to tell you
guys about michael you have a wine that
just came out tell us about the wine i'm
going to tell you the story i'm going to
sum it up
noah's ark when it landed in armenia and
the flood subsided the first vineyards
on earth under the new civilization were
uh grown in armenia at the foot of mount
ararat
transforming for the whole world correct
my story is kind of transforming so a
armenian uh brother of yours not brother
your brother of yours approached me with
this and i got to tell you this i love
this young man i have so much respect
for him he's 23 years old but he's the
exactly the young man that i'm talking
about
raised in a good home his parents are
wonderful he's driven you've been his
one of his idols for the last 10 years
also me he i didn't know when he was 10
years old he was looking at us
unbelievable this is the way kids should
be brought up
because he is going to be a success he
came to me with this whole thing mr
michael he calls me he said you know i
want to brand this wine in your name he
told me the whole story of armenian i
said armenia most wine comes out of you
know italy or france but i love the
story so much and what he said i said
i'm buying into this let's do it and
he's been the power behind this hasn't
been made use the name we're working
together but the wine is great we got uh
five more varieties coming in we're
licensed he did all the work we're going
to be all over the country and now all
over the world we're moving it to the
united kingdom and everywhere else but
it's a great product people are liking
it and uh i'm very happy where can
people get it what can people buy can
get online now you can get direct to
consumer we're we're in almost all 50
states it takes it's a process to get
everywhere and uh again we're going out
so we're going to be global at some
point in time but online sales have been
going very good um we're approaching
costco it looks like they're going to
take it
cisco foods is going to take it will
soon be in ralph's supermarket in la
people are really buying into it and i'm
very proud of the young man you know
what
patrick i like this young man so much
i'm um
i want this to succeed more for him than
i do even for the product what's the
name of the wine exactly is franzia's
wine oh wow frenzy swine where can
people get it michael right now online
at
franziswine.com can you put that link
the link is already in there is it okay
francieswine.com yeah right now we got
three uh three varieties and we got five
more coming in and we put it all through
the taste people are loving it and uh
i'm very i'm this might be the biggest
thing that i ever do how's that one
awesome wow yes well congratulations sam
and to you michael
love the logo i can't wait to try it uh
and uh again folks if you're a wine
drinker go support the wine we'll put
the link below but make sure you buy
mafia democracy as well i think jedidiah
is about to go live if she hasn't
already right she went live at one
o'clock she's going to be on her channel
uh she's blowing up if you guys want to
go
she'll be live are we on we are on
tomorrow oh god status tomorrow get
father is here tomorrow fantastic that's
going to be a lot of fun uh tomorrow as
well so folks have a great one we'll see
you guys tomorrow michael once again
thank you for coming out man this was
awesome thank you take care guys bye bye
bye bye
you